CNN reports Biden says he has decided
how to respond to attack in Jordan he
didn't say exactly how but the previous
reporting was that Biden was considering
striking Iran directly and I mean the
Iranian government their Naval vessels
in the Persian Gulf in response to the
Drone attack that killed three and
injured 34 this many speculate would be
uh could ignite World War III I'm I'm I
got to be honest guys I don't care for
the is it World War III because it's
been said 50 million times over the past
two years by ton of different
politicians across Europe it may be
already happening but I will say this is
this has
been I think it's very clear the
administration's intention was to Target
Iran directly Lindsey Graham called for
it many other politicians called for it
and this would be a unilateral
declaration of war against a major
Nation people in the United States don't
understand they hear Iran and they think
Iraq you look at the map Iraq is not the
same as Iran Iran is a massive
mountainous developed Nation with
resources the reason why it was easy for
the United States to go into Iraq and
Afghanistan less are developed Nations
the reason why the US has struggled to
go after Iran surface to air missiles
and the US relies on air superiority
plus the mountainous mountainous country
going to war with Iran would be massive
I mean the biggest war since I mean I
don't even know I I I imagine you know
it's it's hard to say because during the
the Cold War period all these are
basically proxy wars Vietnam Korea uh
Etc but a war with Iran would be would
be massive Joe Biden may be on the brink
of of of making that move and we can
only hope that if he does Iran decides
not to make a formal
declaration I'm hoping that too uh one
thing I would say is that it's it
wouldn't just be a war with Iran though
it would also be a war with Syria it
would presumptively potentially at least
be a war with Iraq their government
could end up getting overthrown by the
Shia majority and then they install
someone that will side with the Iranians
and the syrians too it would would be
the most major conflict at the very
least since that we've been in since
Vietnam technically since World War II
actually I I don't know enough about the
differing uh views between Iran and
Afghanistan or the Taliban but I'm
wondering well they're Sunni I think
mainly right so I'm wondering what the
possibility that Iran goes to a the
Taliban and says we can maintain those
weapons and that equipment for you have
fun right weaponize the Taliban against
the United States and and and the Us's
allies in the region with all the
weapons left by the United States in
Afghanistan I I swear it's like they did
it on purpose it's absolutely insane
that we are facing war with Iran and
literally next door is billions of
dollars in war machines left by Joe
Biden's failed Administration well Iran
has its own weapon systems too they
they're no slouches when it comes to
missile systems they've done pretty well
for themselves right they wouldn't be
able to achieve air superiority but
definitely trying to occupy an area of
that size is a little bit different from
going into
Gaza or something like that I think that
people yeah I think that people are
underestimating the risk actually and my
hope is that Biden doesn't get his false
flag event or whatever else he needs to
start a war there he gets shuffled out
of office Trump is back he knows how to
negotiate with these countries and then
hopefully we can put the genie back in
the bottle that's the biggest hope do
you think it could hold on for that long
though I really hope so yeah because I
mean the alternative is millions of dead
people probably so I know it's not good
that's that's the hardest thing about
the B Administration which is that it is
volatile and also seems to benefit from
uh the anxiety it creates in voters so
in some ways I could see a scenario
where you know Joe Biden I I don't know
how consciously but wants the American
voters to think we're on the brink of
War for as long as possible which
ultimately creates a much more unstable
position with any other foreign
government that we're negotiating with
the real danger though is that uh you
know that the America's enemies would
like Biden to be reelected and being a
war time president tends to lead to
higher reelect ability now I don't know
that that's the case because Trump is
also he's he's a former president so the
the the metric is different than we've
seen in a long time but the real risk is
that Iran will deliberately antagonize
or one of these other countries
specifically to get Joe Biden
reelected wild it's crazy how obvious it
is that the International Community
regards Trump as the stronger of the two
candidates well I was just thinking like
what if Trump starts negotiating with
people like with the assumption that
he'll be in charge cuz it's kind of like
we saw a little bit of that with the
whole Texas thing when he s saying send
right I was like huh and and when that
happened when Trump said you know other
states who support Texas you should send
your National Guards there was a moment
where I thought Democrats are going to
again go after him for saying I was
afraid to even say that but it's like I
mean Donald Trump is effectively
attempting to act as though he is the
president like like the acting president
or or pseudo president in Exile or
something it's basically an election
strategy it seems to be working he's
four points ahead in the RCP aggregate
almost yeah I mean he's he's running six
and a half points ahead of where he was
at any time in 2016 almost uh 15 points
ahead of where he was in 2020 it's
actually massive and he's about to win
the Nobel Peace Prize I mean this man
can do it all peace key word that is
true word it is interesting that Trump
has uh clearly cemented himself in
opinion as the Republican uh nominee
going forward and we're still sort of
dancing around the primaries like this
is this is going to be a thing that
happens do you have uh do you have
thoughts on Nikki Haley's statement that
she's GNA stay until uh super Tuesday
she she's going to get humiliated in her
home state and she either drops out then
or she stubbornly stays in through the
very end hoping that Donald Trump croaks
or is disqualified in a brokered
convention one of those two things will
happen she either drops right after or
she stays in through the whole thing and
never drops
and just as a thorn in the side we're
doing a live event on March 5th that I
was like we'll do a live super Tuesday
event which makes no sense to be
completely honest because it's not
really super Tuesday it's this weird
pseudo primary where everybody Trump
Tuesday yeah what are you talking about
but because Nikki Haley keeps screeching
like a banshee from the background
people are like I guess there's some
kind of race going on yeah so I I feel
kind honestly I feel bad calling it a
super Tuesday event maybe we should just
call it like Trump wins again Tuesday
just an average Tuesday in
November Tac an average exactly you
should do Taco Tuesday in here and
everyone eats tacos and just like sits
there Nikki Haley was getting votes for
some reason anyway she's 80 points
behind the the I was watching um MSNBC
The Night of the Iowa caucus and they're
all sort of anxious and upset about
what's going on they're like well I mean
what Trump's team is really trying to
figure out if is is if he can get more
than 50% because you know that's the
victory they actually want we don't
think he's going to get it and then he
pulled it like 51 and then New Hampshire
was even higher and I loved it how Dan
santis edged her out I was so so
grateful about that like I was never
Team D santis but I swore up and down I
would never insult Dan santis or any of
his influencers again and I hold by that
if he managed to Edge her out in Iowa
despite being behind in the polls just
by two points but it was just enough so
that Nikki Haley she couldn't even she
didn't even have time to change her
speech you remember that like clearly
she expected to come race it's a two
person race well who are these two
people I am not one of yeah but then Ron
dropped out yeah yeah so he maybe she's
just psychic maybe she knew she was
pressing around to get out uh she's such
a strange candidate to me because she
seems so unlikable and I think South
Carolina is going to be so rough I mean
every there are there any other South
Carolina leading uh elected officials
that can endorse her I mean Henry
McMasters has always been behind Trump
they've all endorsed Trump they've all
it's just here here's a question though
uh you can answer who's more dislikable
Camala Harris or Nikki Haley because for
me it's difficult to actually determine
because I mean they're similar in many
ways so I guess I wonder what like the
only way I can rephrase it is if someone
called you one of the two which would be
more insulting and I don't know that
either uh do you have a guess on who
wait wait you're saying Nikki Haley
versus Kamala Harris which one is more
unlikable Kamala Harris and and if
someone called me Nikki Haley I'd be
like hey if someone called me Kam Harris
I'd be like hey that's true like Kam
Harris is accused of many things in
order to build up her career with brown
no Nikki Haley is too is she really what
yeah no she had several allegations that
she had affairs didn't she and at the
very least she made her husband change
his name
which but like the thing about Nikki
Haley is I'll put it this way would you
rather be called a or a
warmonger it's like I know it's it's a
good question Well's both
apparently well I say this is the
problem as equivalent oh all right well
that's what I was saying it's like
they're not necessarily one's not
necessar better than other than the
other like some people would rather be a
harlot than someone who goes and bombs
kids you know what I mean I'd rather be
a harot than bomb kid see that's that's
that's the difficult thing I think both
of them want to be both though that's
the problem which is also upsetting
that's really that's like a funny bit
KLA Harris and Nikki Haley arguing with
each other in a VP debate over who was
going to kill more
kids become one to the other one Nikki
Haley isn't going to be Trump's VP nope
no who do you think Trump would pick as
a VP uh I I don't know exactly who but
here's here's my general thoughts it'll
either be a charismatic female so
somebody like a Cary lakeer or Tulsi
gabard or a non-charismatic male Trump
cannot be on stage with another
charismatic male who will steal anything
of the spotlight that's why he chose
Pence to sit in the background that's
why I don't think it'll be ramas Swami
or Tucker Carlson they'd both be fine
choices but I think they're off the
table non-charismatic unassuming like
like Tim Scott male Doug if it's female
Trump trump has no problem with a with a
fiery female being got be I think
Christy Nome is a good choice for him VP
is not about the second best it's about
who gets Trump a demographic he doesn't
get Chris Christy gnome can help him get
Suburban women absolutely especially
considering what's going on with Joe
Biden economics in schools you get a
middle-aged woman with Charisma and
Trump is is it's it's great he needs
that yeah I think I think chrisy Nome is
definitely in the top three or four I
think tulsey gabbard's probably up there
too you could definitely you could
definitely do worse she has really had a
Redemption Arc number one and number two
she is very well spoken yeah she she's
got a lot of uh Charisma and she's a
former Dem so she brings potentially
some left leing Independence to say well
you know Donald Cho she used to be the
Democrat I'm kind of a soft Democrat may
could work anti-war leftists would be
like I don't like Trump but I think
Tulsi in there is good this why I was
saying uh in 20 like 2020 that if Trump
chose Andrew Yang as an economic adviser
and announced that he'd be cabinet
position and tulsey gabard as National
Security adviser he'd win in the
landslide of course the left took that
statement and clipped out the part where
I said he's going to win in a landslide
and cut out the context of if he
legalized marijuana pardoned all the
people in federal prison over marijuana
dealing and then made Tulsi gabber but
uh I I digress Tulsi gabard uh as
someone advising him on National
Security is exactly what most populists
want to hear no Wars there was an
amazing article uh I think it was it
what was it Pat Buchanan the American
conservative whatever said said fire
Bolton hire telsey gabard this is a a a
conservative fire brand saying Tulsi
gabard should be in that position
because she won't get us involved in
these Garbage Wars we can all agree hey
we don't like her policy on guns or
whatever she's she's evolved on these
issues but she was against nuclear
energy and she was for gun control these
are bad things but she has military
service she opposes foreign intervention
and put her in that position and Trump
jumped several Trump's jumping several
points the the military service part
would be a big thing as well especially
since one of the things Trump is going
to have to do if he's reelected is
reform the military oh yeah he he's I
mean he's got to deify it you've got to
get the recruitment levels up preferably
keep it State side or in Allied
countries and not send it over into Iran
like Biden apparently plans possibly to
do uh if he's going to do that having a
v who could go directly to the Troops
who could go to like the recruitment
center and stuff and actually like level
with people I think would be very very
important thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net